hello and welcome to
all and thank you for meeting us in the
press room today
danaé month for the first meeting of the
open commission in hatred it
is Monday, December 2
excuse us for the slight delay we
wanted to listen  the
president's intervention at coop 25 before
starting the meeting and then we
got the wrong door to come
to the press room it's the enemy it's
the beginning so the end of dallas commission
took office yesterday and as soon as  yesterday
on the occasion of taking office
the president attended, as you
know, a ceremony organized at the
house of european history in
brussels on the occasion of the tenth
anniversary of the treaty of lisbon
you will find more information
including  the speech that the president
delivered on this occasion online in
the daily news
the president also began a
series of telephone calls to her
interlocutors our members of the
euro union  pean of the g20 and the g7 and his calls will
continue in the coming days
tomorrow at 11 a.m. the
official handover of power between
president jean claude juncker and
president fender hatred
will take place which you can follow live on bs
european commission in palma
prove  -the witch
jean haja stakeholders chilly sachy daily
news express 6 pin up one with tab
condemns acts in the northwest where
files and finally on behalf of the commission
I would also like to express our
condolences to france which has been the
victim of the violent  bad weather at this
weekend which cost the lives of five
people including three rescuers
the spli the friend welcome to the press like
a divider group bump and sewers
can endure joe cole is a group i
can talk and your story tour mira works
in three sentences form no there is